yeah what for people who don't know
because I saw I mean you lost a lot of
your personal friend I think you lost
like 12 friends in a year no eight and
two eight years eight friends in two
years yeah so that's gotta be like three
of them was family members uh an older
cousin uh a younger cousin
and uh because around my age it's crazy
because we we hear that same story
coming from so many people from your
city right and it's like you know G
herbo has a song called PTSD and he
talks a lot about like uh the mental
strength you have to have to be from
where he's from where you're from you
know what I'm saying and and to deal
with so much loss and so much hurt like
do you ever feel like you had an
opportunity to really mourn
um
yeah behind closed doors when you were
by yourself you know what I'm saying but
um
you grow
I mean numb to it you know what I'm
saying you get used to it I wouldn't say
numb to it because you still care but no
but it's it's used to it yeah I mean
it's something you can get used to if
you get there's women out here who are
getting cheated on by the same guy for a
decade who I know and I'm like well
you're just used to it at this point
like you don't even care anymore like
you like [__] happens to you and
unfortunately no matter how traumatic it
is like you're kind of conditioned to
deal with it you know what I'm saying
yeah I always say it could be worse
that's I mean everything could always be
worse so [__] 100 do you ever feel like
uh you have ever like
consider maybe hitting therapy talking
out some of your [__] like that um I
tried that before oh you did yeah like
uh
talking to somebody all the time
it worked a little bit it's cool yeah
but um I'd rather just do music for real
like that is your therapy yeah that's
what it is I love that
this album you're about to release is
your first album as an independent
artist right which is a big deal yeah
um this is a new space for you uh to be
who you are with already with a five
times platinum record and now you're
able to kind of move freely you're able
to kind of call the shots do what you
want to do how does it feel like like is
is it something
there's got to be like a cool
Just Energy to that yeah yeah yeah I
feel free I don't know why I keep saying
that but that's what it feels like you
feel like a a weight is off my shoulder
you know I get to see certain things you
know what I'm saying I get to move how I
want to I mean it's just a better
positive energy all the way around you
know what I'm saying that's how I feel
you know so I'm excited for it I was
gonna say what would you say is your was
your biggest
um for people who think you just
disappeared what would you attribute
that to the reason of that is it the is
it the label thing or is it just
like what was it what was what's the
reason why we haven't gotten a lot of
music from you in the last few years
yeah it's a label thing yeah it was a
label thing bro for sure is it hard to
still stay motivated if you feel like
you're kind of like
no
um
I'm still living yeah you know my two
feet still move you know what I'm saying
so I mean I'm grateful for that yeah and
I can work and I can grind I can do what
I want to do still so I love it man I
ain't tripping I always stay motivated
uh